food we can't live without it especially
when Donuts exist and food affects every
aspect of our world we're not just
talking about breakfast lunch and dinner
it's part of our traditions our health
even our politics companies like
kellogg's and coca-cola have spent
millions of dollars trying to prevent
these changes global warming threatens
our favorite foods this is the cocoa pod
that grows on the tree and in it are the
beans that actually have the chocolate
so these are the bad boys that are in
danger by climate change over the next
few weeks aj+ is talking about all the
news that's fit to eat the food is
really good yes there are politics
related to food from what's hiding in
your food did you know that seventy
percent of processed foods that we eat
has at least one GMO ingredient in it to
how food scarcity impacts communities
around the world over the past three
decades famines have claimed the lives
of over a million people in the Horn of
Africa and even the history of some of
the tastiest dishes there's still a
question on exactly when and where
chickpeas and tahini first got messy the
most trace it back to 13th century Egypt
watch aj+ as we tuck into the stories
that matter to you this is so good
you